pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
una d'allemagne de gymnastique à hulme
2000 personnes ont eu la chance
d'assister à ces championnats c'est en
effet un admirable spectacle comme vous
pouvez en juger par l'exhibition du
munichois lothar lanz winter jakobi au
cheval d'arçons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
forte de précision beauté du geste
audace audace plus grande encore pour
philippe furst à la barre fixe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des skieurs français à l'heure des
récompenses après le retour des états
unis monsieur maurice herzog remettent à
jean biart n'est la cravate de l'ordre
du mérite sportif
cravate également pour honoré bonnet
l'entraîneur de l'équipe de france
[Musique]
pour vous qui périt ya ce sera une
médaille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et propose aussi adrien du billard vous
êtes jeune vous avez encore le temps
d'accrocher une cravate à votre cou tout
comme votre aîné jean vianney puisqu'il
est question de champion parlons un peu
de ces universités britanniques face à
des chopes de bière ils ont tenté de
battre un record de vitesse dont
l'originalité n'échappera à personne
le règlement nous reconnaît évidemment
comme valable que la quantité de liquide
qui passe directement dans le gosier à
l'exclusion de ce que peut voir la
serpillière pour amateurs de bière que
soient les anglais l'entreprise n'était
donc pas si simple
[Musique]
il se trouve un montant finalement un
concurrent pour vider sa chope
proprement en 12 secondes
[Musique]
si je m'en voyez la suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
guy dira le rôle éminemment social du
chapeau jadis à une époque qui passait
pour savoir vivre le choix d'un couvre
chef constituait une opération de
première importance n'y ait pas de la
dignité de tous les événements
essentiels de l'existence autrement plus
sérieuses ou le hot 100
les manifestations de masse elle même
n'y gagnent leur indélicatesse entre
gens si bien chapeautée de parts et
d'autres
comment imaginer qu il peut rester une
place pour la bagarre
[Musique]
autre avantage qui avait son prix l'arc
se reconnaissait au premier coup d'oeil
il en était de même du don juin de 14
juillet quand il est vrai que le chapeau
était un moyen d'affirmer sa
personnalité
[Musique]
en pleine action le sportif ça avait
donné le coup de chapeau qui prenait
tout son sens en politique large et
présidentielles ou secs et dictatorial
chez les ministrables
il pouvait aisément se donner à droite
et à gauche
sur le coeur façon trop mal résigné
façon nintendo mais la guerre sonné le
glas du chapeau les hommes se
retrouvaient terriblement nu il faut
dire que l'exemple venait de haut et
tout à coup on a vu la jeunesse
l'adopter mais avec une préférence
marquée pour le fringant tyrolien
et les autres générations ont suivi
pourtant en dehors de cas particuliers
pour lesquels le couvre-chef obligatoire
est une seconde nature
il faut bien reconnaître que le
maniement du chapeau au caire une
certaine réadaptation
les circonstances et d'engagement que
chacun s'y remettra très vite
la nouvelle vague quant à elle ne semble
pas se poser de problème et porte le
chapeau avec brio et intrépidité
[Applaudissements]
même dans les opérations tactiques les
plus délicates on peut s'en sortir à son
avantage
les gens peuvent affirmer leur
réputation
les autres trouvé l'occasion de soigner
leur avancement
et chacun il trouvera son compte
[Musique]
en prélude à la visite de monsieur k
paris a reçu un autre monsieur k
khatchatryan l'auteur de la célèbre
danse du sabre et avec chostakovitch le
plus prestigieux des compositeurs
soviétique
[Musique]
il
en avant-première du récital qu'il
donnera au conte sa colonne il fait
répéter pour la dernière fois son
concerto pour violon à leonid kogan l'un
des plus grands peut-être le plus grand
des violonistes du monde
[Musique]
je suis heureux de rencontrer le
président de la république française
dira tout à l'heure le président du
conseil de l'urss au général de gaulle
venus l'accueillir à sa descente d'avion
c'était la première fois que ces deux
hommes aux destins aussi différents
qu'exceptionnelle se trouvaient réunis
premier contact premières paroles
échangées
monsieur le président eh bien vous voici
je puis vous assurer que nous en sommes
très contents avoue meurt à madame
khrouchtchev à votre famille à vos
compagnons
je souhaite la bienvenue puis monsieur
khrouchtchev transmis taux français le
salut cordial du peuple soviétique
une équipe française qui n'a dans un
amphithéâtre france aux cadres urbains
l'admiration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
haute de la france pendant douze jours
monsieur coach aux côtés du président de
la république allait prendre un premier
contact avec la foule parisienne
sur le chemin qui le conduisait à sa
résidence du quai d'orsay et de là au
palais de l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette réception allait être l'occasion
d'un premier entretien
monsieur k devait remettre à son hôte un
cadeau qu'il semble prodigue une
réplique du spoutnik
une courte détente
[Musique]
et monsieur coach of et le général de
gaulle remonter les champs elysées où
l'attendait une foule curieuse
d'apercevoir l'homme qui porte le destin
de 212 millions de soviétiques
[Applaudissements]
pleurs pourtant les pas ici aux
perspectives de la politique
internationale pendant le tombeau du
soldat inconnu
le président krotov est venu accomplir
un geste traditionnel en se rappelant
sans doute un passé récent de souffrance
commune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hamad
avec une émotion plus grande encore que
le président du conseil de l'urss devait
au mont valérien se recueillir devant le
mur des 4500 fusillés de la résistance
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de retour au quai d'orsay madame nîmes a
coaché va s'occuper pas faire plus ample
connaissance avec sa résidence
[Musique]
de son côté monsieur k mettait à profit
le premier creux de son programme en
recevant des invités personnels au
milieu d'un aimable brouard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le soir enfin au palais de l'elysée le
président soviétique devait retrouver de
nouveau le président de la république
ils avaient ensemble rendez vous avec le
tout paris de la politique
[Musique]
c'est dans l'éclat de cette brillante
réception que s'achevait cette première
journée d'une rencontre dont à un mois
de la conférence au sommet le général de
gaulle a fixé la signification en ces
termes nous sommes prêts à vous entendre
et à nous faire entendre
à vous voir et à nous faire voir
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]